when you guys teamed up the first time a
lot of people saw your video they they
were surprised and some people might
have thought of it as a risk did you
guys think of it that way at all it was
a surprise to us actually we sang
together in a studio and then we're
immediately
shocked if you like that that our voices
blended because on paper you wouldn't
think so but actually this there's
something that happens between the two
of us that not only personally but also
musically that it's quite engaging and
we recognized that immediately and then
that led to another song and another
song and so we ended up with the whole
album that was sting and shame I mean
there's there's always a certain amount
of risk but it wouldn't be interesting
if it wasn't there was a risk involved
you know and I think that's part of what
lured us to it mm-hmm and the people
around you your team your family is when
they found out oh you know what you guys
want to do this thing together what was
the common reaction skepticism doubt on
my side they were very supportive but I
still think they were sitting there okay
let me hear what this really sounds like
right you know see that an audience is
you know and that when they come and see
us first of all that little wary and
then very quickly that we're in a sense
of surprise and then joy and so we're
very confident about what we have as a
package so it works every night but I'd
like audiences making a journey you know
if you start with it I was raving
there's no way you can take them so we
take them on a journey that is full of
surprises for us too yeah well and then
show the show is structured like a
journey to it's like almost like a
roller coaster ride through time but at
the same time with these new songs being
positioned at specific places and there
you know it introduces them to the album
you know with little sparkles of you
know or hits here and there and then
there's a combination of him and I
singing each other songs together so
that that works well what was surprising
about working with each other I mean did
you have any sort of preconceived
notions about how Shaggy's artistic
process might go what surprised you I
mean I had no idea what is this process
was but I recognized a consummate
musician when I worked with him and he's
much more spontaneous than I am he can
create a song on the spot and forced me
into that mode and that's a completely
opposite to what the way I work I'm
normally much more prepared and private
and anxious you know before I present
anything to anybody but he just comes
out with it yeah and so that encouraged
he encouraged me to do that and I think
I'd benefited from that on the other
side I encouraged him to sing more
because he's a very good singer and
you'd say well you know I'm MC rapper
blanks myself saying but he he and
what's so beautiful about this pairing
and it is the fact that we both take
each other out of a comfort zone and
what I love about him is is he's not
scared to try things
he'll try several things you know I mean
and that's that's what it is when you
know when he speaks about being
spontaneous it's half the time it's just
gibberish and melodic ideas and him and
I to get a boost I'm just beside each
other the mics to just throw it out
throw ideas out and out of that will
come a song and later on it will develop
you know where we put words and we'll
change little things here and there but
at least the initial idea is there and
we could say oh yeah we like this are
known and and at that point we could
realize that together that we have
something and there doesn't really have
don't even even think we ever ran into
any blocks where was like I wouldn't
like this or that you know there's
something it was like I think we should
change we're just kind of going it you
know I might go to miss a change that
and you just kind of flows with it we
just had fun I mean what comes off the
record is just fun people that really
enjoy
what they're doing yeah I think a lot of
the when people look at an artist has
been around for a long time they might
look at them and go this is their lane
like this is what they do this whole
thing for you guys was one of the
purposes of this to be like I'm gonna
break out of that I'm gonna let people
know that there's that there's more they
can collaborate with this other artist
it was that one thing that you guys want
to do on purpose well you know I have a
history of surprising people with you
know choices that aren't necessarily
logical but I do that to keep myself
amused you know and keep the audience
guessing you know that's been my modus
for a long time
and I think it was the same with him you
know he doesn't make records that you
expect against the grain yeah because
you like you like that element of I will
never outstay my welcome in anything you
know I mean you'll never be bored of me
before I'm bored of me I'm gonna be
bored of me way before you start getting
bored of me so I don't try not to repeat
myself I always go against the grain and
I don't like to follow what is going on
I mean when we did take for instance a
mr. boombastic you know or or say it
wasn't me when we came out wasn't me it
was in the era of the insync the Britney
Spears that was the type of music that
was very popular and there I come left
field with this thing that people don't
know is like what you know I mean and
and that becomes in and it's the same
thing with all Carolina same thing would
mr. mr. bombastic they're not
traditional reggae yeah they're a bit of
a hybrid but that's what's intriguing
about it that's what's exciting for me I
was raised on traditional reggae and I
love it
but my argument was like am I gonna do
the same exact thing as Bob Marley am I
gonna do my own thing you know I mean to
make my own mark
I cannot top what Bob Marley have done
you know and Greg rise like a repeater
Tosh or any of these guys could they did
it's so damn good there's no topping
them you know I mean so if you're gonna
do exactly what they do and claim to be
better than them at it try again it's
not how
and I'm saying so you have to find your
own little little way of doing things
and and even staying with the police was
the same thing I would imagine too
because they they had this whole hybrid
sound that that y'all experimented with
but reggae you know that that was very
instrumental to the development of
reggae music and the popularity of
reggae music because they were the
bridge they were kind of the
breakthrough band that brought it to the
mainstream I want to know more about
this point where you know you said you
don't like hearing yourself sing yet
you're singing on tracks how did you get
him to do it like how did you get him to
be okay with saving on the song break
his arm and put it up light Russia and
he just has to do it there's a little of
confidence that comes with that when you
have a hundred and odd million selling
eighteen time Grammy - I get the Nomura
door 19 whose company I'm saying yeah
saying to you in a trusted musician I
trusted him with that that was why I
ended up doing it because in working
with him I trusted him
and I tell you what when he asked me to
do it first I actually I don't remember
that day I said I said no you pulled me
aside and says are you refusing me and I
went home and I thought about it I was
like dude just do just challenge me yeah
you know and I came back next day I say
let me see them lyrics and he's a good
singer I started doing it and it was
like see
but then he vocal produced it so while I
was while I was doing the vocals and the
boot he was the one that was taking the
vocals and be like nah move this note
like this to sing it this way put that
that way or and when he came when it was
done and that and we did the balance and
I was like okay I'm not mad at that